let's start this story at a cafe in West
London it's July 2016 and David Cameron
comes here after resigning his prime
minister and handing over to Tories in
May he's joined for coffee by George
Osborne the Chancellor who had just that
morning being sacked by mrs. main
well Osborne had opposed a referendum
that saying it would be divisive but now
these two men who had dominated British
politics for the previous six years were
both suddenly out of office and there
was a new word dominating the British
political scene brexit Teresa may had
backed remain but she launched her
leadership bid with a phrase that we
would come to hear a lot brexit knees
brexit she wasn't the only candidate
Boris Johnson had been the favorite but
pulled out of the contest after learning
that Michael Gove his vote leave Ally
was going to join the leadership race
that I'll seize this chance and make
this our moment to stand tall in the
world that is the agenda for the next
prime minister of this country I have
concluded that person cannot be me in
the end
there were four rivals but Mrs May one
the leadership battle with some ease and
on the steps of Downing Street she
promised to fight against the burning in
justices mrs. Mae came here to Lancaster
House to give her first in-depth speech
about her vision of what brexit meant
and it was amazingly detailed twelve
distinct objectives that would define
her ambition but which also would really
restrict her room for manoeuvre we will
take back control of our laws and bring
an end to the jurisdiction of the
European Court of Justice in Britain a
global Britain must be free to strike
trade agreements with countries from
outside the European Union to
more speeches followed in Florence and
then at the mansion house but then came
a big important twist not in Parliament
but on the other side of the square in
the Supreme Court no Prime Minister no
government can expect to be unanswerable
or unchallenged Parliament alone is
sovereign it was here that a business
woman called Gina Miller won a legal
action against the government which
meant that any brexit deal would have to
be voted through Parliament and if it
wasn't for that legal victory we may not
have had the political deadlock that
we're now seeing MPs did give the Prime
Minister permission to trigger the
process of leaving the EU but not before
they'd won the right to a so-called
meaningful vote so they could block the
deal if they didn't like it but despite
these wobbles the opinion polls had mrs.
May looking pretty comfortable so she
decided to call a general election
confident that an enlarged majority
would help her hand in negotiating Breck
said it will be a choice between strong
and stable leadership in the national
interest with me as your prime minister
or weak and unstable coalition
government led by Jeremy Corbyn the
problem was that something curious was
sleeping with labour the party had needs
sharply to the left and Jeremy Corbyn
had found a new well of support labour
didn't win the election but they did a
road the conservative majority
and Teresa may found herself now having
to form a minority government in return
for more money for Northern Ireland she
got support from the Democratic Unionist
Party and Northern Ireland was just
about to become the biggest stumbling
block embrace it
both sides committed to avoiding the
return of a physical hard border between
Northern Ireland and the Republic but
nobody could work out what should be
there in its place how to manage a
border without actually imposing it it
became the great unanswerable it's a
question of whether we're separating the
Union whether we are dealing with the
United Kingdom in a way that that leaves
us adrift in the future and as the
leader of unionism in Northern Ireland
I'm not about to agree to that
the UK and EU negotiators instead agree
to a compromise known as the backstop
which would mean Northern Ireland
abiding by European trade laws until a
better option came along mrs. may sign
that in December 2017 but the discontent
slowly grew by the summer the strain was
obvious so she summoned her cabinet for
a meeting
amidst the quiet and solitude of the
Prime Minister's country residence
Checker's this said mrs. May was her
view of the UK's future relationship
with Europe it was time for her team to
get behind it and not all of them did
next day David Davis resigned as brexit
secretary saying the Checker's plan was
too soft he was followed out of cabinet
by Boris Johnson the Foreign Secretary a
lightning rod for many in the leave
campaign who departed saying the UK was
heading for the status of a European
colony
dissent became endemic dominate robbed
took over as brexit secretary and then
resigned a few months later more
resignations followed in yet the prime
minister persevered now critics were now
emboldened they saw the Prime Minister
as a reluctant director tear a remainer
who never really believed in the brexit
she was negotiating you have streams of
talent within the Conservative Party who
would be very capable of support of
leading a proper braixen the withdrawal
agreement published the future
relationship set out and widely derided
and nothing could change the
parliamentary arithmetic there was no
majority for the deal everyone knew if
we went ahead and held the votes
tomorrow the deal would be rejected she
set off on a frantic dash around Europe
to drum up support to try to eke out
fresh concessions a journey curtailed by
summons back to Downing Street to face a
vote of no-confidence from her own
colleagues and now it comes to this the
eyes of the world trained on Westminster
intrigue and yes baffled by how the path
to brexit could have become so
extraordinarily difficult
Adam Parsons Sky News